[Music]
this pure consciousness of absolute
being is an alienated consciousness we
have now to look more closely at the
specific nature of that of which it is
the other and we must consider it only
in connection with this other to begin
with this pure consciousness seems to
have over against it only the world of
actuality but since it is the flight
from this world and therefore has the
character of an antithesis to it it
bears this world within itself
pure consciousness is therefore in its
own self alienated from itself and faith
continues only one aspect of it at the
same time the other aspect has already
come to view pure consciousness namely
is reflection out of the world of
culture in such a way that the substance
of that world and also the masses or
groups into which it is articulated are
shown to be what they are in themselves
spiritual essentiality z-- absolute
Restless processes or determinations
which are directly cancelled in their
opposite their essence simple
consciousness is thus the simplicity of
absolute difference which is and wants
no difference consequently it is pure
being for self not as this single self
but as the imminently universal self in
the form of a restless process which
attacks and pervades the passive essence
of the matter in hand in it is thus to
be found the certainty that at once
knows itself to be the truth pure
thought as the absolute notion in the
might of its negativity which eliminates
everything objective that supposedly
stands over against consciousness and
makes it into a being which has its
origin in consciousness this pure
consciousness is at the same time
equally simple just because it's
difference is no difference but as this
form of simple reflection into self it
is the element of faith in which spirit
has the determinant of positive
universality of being in itself in
contrast
being for self of self-consciousness
forced back into itself out of the
essence list merely dissolving world
spirit in accordance with its truth is
in an undivided unity at once the
absolute movement and negativity of its
process of manifestation as well as its
inwardly satisfied essence in its
positive repose becoming generally under
the determinate nests of alienation
these two moments fall apart into a dual
consciousness the former is pure insight
as the spiritual process which focuses
itself in self consciousness a process
which is confronted by consciousness of
what is positive the form of objectivity
or of picture thinking and which turns
against it but pure insights own object
is only the pure eye the simple
consciousness of the positive or of
tranquil self identity on the other hand
has for its object the inner essence qua
essence pure insight has therefore in
the first instance no content of its own
because it is negative being for self to
faith on the other hand there belongs a
content but without insight if the
former does not step outside self
consciousness the latter certainly has
its content in the element of pure self
consciousness but in thought not in
notions in pure consciousness not in
pure self consciousness
hence faith is certainly pure
consciousness of essence that is of the
simple inner being and thus is thought
the Cardinal factor in the nature of
faith which is usually overlooked the
immediacy of the presence of essence in
it is due to the fact that it's object
is essence that is pure thought this
immediacy however so far as thought
enters into consciousness or pure
consciousness enters into self
consciousness acquires the significance
of an objective being which lies beyond
the consciousness of the self it is
through this significance which the
immediacy and simplicity of pure thought
obtains in consciousness that the
essence of faith is no longer a pure
thought but is reduced to the level of
something a man
becomes a super sensible world which is
essentially an other in relation to
self-consciousness in pure insight on
the other hand the transition of pure
thought into consciousness has the
opposite determination objectivity has
the significance of a merely negative
content a content which is reduced to a
moment and returns into the self that is
to say only the self is really the
object of the self or the object only
has truth so far as it has the form of
the self
we now have a very long paragraph in
which there's a lot of stuff going on at
Hegel's telling us a lot about the
orientation of consciousness in this
this new stage in paragraph 529 so he
begins by talking about the pure
consciousness of absolute being being an
alienated consciousness and he says we
now have to look more closely at the
specific nature of that of which it is
the other so he's introducing really
reintroducing a classic thematic by this
point what is the other what is the the
thing that opposes or stands on the the
I almost used other side to
consciousness and and self-consciousness
what is it that it's in another sense
seeking some sort of recognition from or
at least a reassimilation to is its
other in this case something merely to
be grappled with consumed mastered or is
the other something from which it's
going to learn who and what it is that's
a great question for thinking in terms
of religion and remember as we go into
this that Hegel at this point is talking
about religion as not really fully
understanding what it's up to the
religious consciousness is certainly
doing something and has ideas but it's
not fully grasping them so he says we
also have to look we have to look at
this only in connection with this other
so what is what is the other so he says
well in one sense the other could be the
world of actuality pure consciousness
has over against at the world of
actuality the world of culture the world
that we've gone through in all this
great stuff in spirit and reason and
self consciousness
even in consciousness the very beginning
parts the world of actuality the world
of stuff in which we experience and then
he says but since it is the flight from
this world and therefore has the
character of an antithesis
Gagan Zots to it it bears this world
within itself now isn't that an
interesting thing to say as it tries to
escape this world of actuality it
imports that very world of actuality
into itself in some sort of form we
could say it internalizes it it's it's
flight is a attempt to get away from
something and insofar as it's still
running away it's still conditioned by
that from which it is running away so it
carries it along inside of itself by
doing so now why did I try to run away
from this world because it was finding
that world alienating that means that
self consciousness or consciousness
rather at this point is alienated from
itself by fleeing the very world in
which that alienation was taking place
which was its reason for saying I'm
getting the hell out of here
so he says pure consciousness is
therefore in its own self alienated from
itself and faith constitutes only one
aspect of it what is this what is this
little introduction thing here so faith
is only one of the things going on in
that alienated self-consciousness what
what else is going on well what Hegel is
going to call insight is also going on
so now we have a duality being
introduced in the heart of consciousness
itself as we see so often within the
Hegelian dialectic these are in
antithesis to each other one is not the
thesis and the other the antithesis
they're both antitheses to each other
so he goes on and he tells us at the
same time the other aspect has come into
view pure consciousness is the
reflection out of the world of culture
in such a way that the substance of that
world and also the masses notice he's
using this term masses that he was using
earlier about what the ethical substance
in what in the spirit section but also
much earlier even in the reason section
so the the masses or groups or aspects
into which the substance of that world
is articulated he says they're shown to
be what they are in themselves spiritual
essentiality 'he's absolutely restless
processes or determinations which are
directly cancelled in their opposite
okay nothing new there that's stuff that
we covered earlier in the the section
that just preceded this in you know over
the scope of about 10 to 12 paragraphs
right it took us a long time to work our
way through that so that's not something
new but what is new is that is being
brought into the world of pure
consciousness which was supposed to be
an escape from that wasn't it so he says
their essence simple consciousness is
thus the simplicity of absolute
difference which is at once no
difference this is a phrase that Hegel
has used before absolute difference
which is no difference there's there's a
another dualism going on here absolute
difference no difference consciousness
is is both of these at the same time
difference of what of its contents which
are these spiritual masses or aspects or
whatever we want to call them in the
previous section they were you know the
notions of good and bad as well as state
power and wealth and noble and ignoble
consciousness so he goes out and he says
consequently it is pure being for self
not as this single self but as the
imminently universal self in the form of
a restless process which attacks and
pervades the passive essence of the
matter in hand
notice again an
friends to something that we've talked
about quite a bit the Zakas ELPS
something that i translated a little bit
daringly at some points as the project
as what it is that one is investing one
oneself into and saying this is what
really matters that's over here now is
this perhaps the other if the world
wasn't really the other because it's
being brought along perhaps this is the
other two it he goes on and he says it's
thus it is in it is us to be found a
certainty that it once knows itself to
be the truth pure being for self is a
certainty that knows itself to be the
truth again we see these these hay
galleon ideas that are so often stripped
apart from each other you get to have
certainty but you lose truth you get to
have truth but you lose certainty it's
so rare that you get both of them at the
same time it's almost like the UH the
uncertainty principle all right you can
have one side but you can't have the
other well in this case Hegel saying you
actually have both of these at the same
time and not only are you getting
certainty in truth it is a certainty
that knows itself to be the truth that
sounds pretty good doesn't it so he goes
on Annie says here we go pure thought as
the absolute notion the absolute concept
in the might of its negativity which
eliminates everything objective that
supposedly stands over against
consciousness and makes it into a being
which has its origin in consciousness so
this pure consciousness he says is it at
the same time equally simple but as this
form of simple reflection into itself it
is he says the element of faith in which
spirit has the terminus of positive
universality when we have faith we have
faith in something it is not content
less it doesn't for Hegel it doesn't
make sense to talk about just faith you
know per se it's always faith in faith
towards faith of
it's got some object I believe that I
mean you could say I have faith that
they're both good translations of globba
right I believe something so there is an
absolute that's being given there but
now it's a positive absolute not a
merely negative corrosive absolute so he
goes on and he says this is being in
itself in contrast to that being for
self of self consciousness aha we're
getting a contrast here being in itself
in faith being for itself in something
different so now he says forced back
into itself out of this essence 'less
merely dissolving world there's a world
over here that seems to be falling apart
and it's sort of a you know an image of
what was going out of the world of
actuality the world of culture he says
spirit in accordance with its truth is
in an undivided unity at once the
absolute movement and negativity of its
process of manifestation as well as its
inwardly satisfied essence and it's
positive repose and now notice what he
said this all sounds very good right
we've made some real progress Hegel as
he does so often now pulls the rug out
from under you
so he says coming generally under the
determinists of alienation
so because consciousness is alienated
right these two moments fall apart into
a dual consciousness
what are these aspects of the dual
consciousness well we get insight and
faith faith is the positive insight is
the negative both of them are real both
of them exist both of them are there in
consciousness and boy is that a struggle
for the person who has both of them in
the same consciousness sometimes if
we're talking about world history here
we might have the person who's primarily
motivated by faith and the person who is
primarily motivated by insight it's
probably easier for them but they're in
a certain sense incomplete neither one
of them is a full consciousness
the person who's a full consciousness at
this state is actually grappling with
both of these at the same time so let's
let's talk about the inside part he says
pure insight is a spiritual process
which focuses itself in self
consciousness not just consciousness but
self consciousness it is for itself and
he says a process which is confronted by
consciousness of what is positive so
what faith is taking to be real insight
is looking at and saying ah I don't know
about that let me take a closer look
you've assumed some stuff here I don't
know if that really is the way that
you're presenting it so he says it looks
at the form of objectivity it looks at
picture thinking what we earlier talked
about is force telling representation
and what turns against it and then he
says pure incites object is only the
pure eye the simple consciousness of the
positive tranquil self identity has for
its object the inner essence quite
essence it says so pure insight doesn't
have any content of its own it's a
negative being for self so pure insight
can really only work it's like I put
here it's critical it can only work as a
judge it has to have something supplied
from somewhere this is actually a
problem with insight it's not as if you
could have insight totally existing on
its own it's in a certain way
parasitical upon believing in something
or somebody at least postulating or
putting forward something you can't
criticize if nobody sets something out
there for you to criticize and when you
do criticize insight is pretty good at
that let's talk about faith now so he
says for faith there belongs the content
but without insight so we've got a we've
got an alienation here we've got a split
right things aren't quite so resolved as
we liked not at all so he says
if pure insight doesn't step outside
self-consciousness the latter certainly
has its content in the elements of pure
self-consciousness but not in notions
not in concepts be Griff but in thoughts
in pure consciousness but not in pure
self-consciousness
so it's conscious but it's not really
aware of its own involvement in that
that consciousness
so he says faith is certainly pure
consciousness of essence that is of the
simple inner being and thus is thought
but he says this is the cart and this is
a very important point the Cardinal
factor in the nature of faith which is
usually overlooked oftentimes faith gets
gets posed as if it is like you don't
really have faith unless you just kind
of feel things right if you start making
it propositional or you start thinking
too much it's not really faith man Hegel
says well that's nonsense I mean that's
you can have faith in that sense that's
like feeling faith right and and cool or
feeling or effect that's the lowest
level buddy higher than that is faith
where you can actually tell people what
the hell you have faith in you can
represent it in some way and that's for
styling and that's what that's what
faith really is and forced along is a
form of thinking actually even feeling
is thinking to in a certain sense
I mean Descartes knew this right
Hobbes knew this Hume knew this but
they're not thoughts in the same let's
say articulate Nisour Stalin as
representation or picture thinking so he
goes on and he says here we go the
immediacy of the presence of essence in
it is due to the fact that it's object
is essence it's object is pure thought
this immediacy insofar as thought enters
into consciousness or now notice what he
says here or pure consciousness enters
into self consciousness isn't that an
interesting phrase pure consciousness
and
into self-consciousness acquires the
significance of an objective being
that's he says this is how we generate
an other for the self in this case
remember this is this whole paragraph is
about what's the other what's the other
to this this consciousness so he says it
generates an objective being alright
which lies beyond the consciousness of
the self they says it's through this
significance which the immediacy and
simplicity of pure thought obtains them
consciousness that the essence of faith
is no longer a pure thought but is
reduced to the level of something
imagined and becomes again what's going
on over here a super sensible world
which is essentially an other in
relation to self consciousness and the
other that is not yet fully known and
other which has become put out there as
something different than the self
consciousness or the consciousness and
faith says aha this is my relation I I
think that I I understand it through the
pictures or you know the language that
I'm using to represent that
that's what Hegel takes faith to be
doing whether it's involving feelings
whether it's involving rituals whether
it's involving actions faith is is
essentially I don't even want to say
propositional it's picturing right so
it's not you could have propositions
that are that are tied in with the
concept and are more a matter of insight
in this case so he goes on and he says
here we go in pure insight the
transition of pure thought into
consciousness has the opposite
determination objectivity becomes a
merely negative content it's not good to
be objective because that means you can
criticize it that means that you can
point out its flaws you can point out
the problems in the analogies you can
point out how the pictures don't
actually depict what they're supposed to
so he says we
content which is reduced to a moment and
returns into the self and he says that
is to say only the self is really the
object of the South in pure insight or
the object only has truth so far as it
as the form of the self what does he
mean there does he mean that we're like
turning inward and only looking at
ourselves he says no no no that's not
what he means the object has its its its
truth
insofar as it is a form of the self
meaning it is for the self it exists for
me as consciousness not just out there
by itself and then me discovering it
it's rather conditioned by my own
consciousness that's the insight of
insights so now we're going to see these
two played off against each other
through the rest of this section
you